hello
my name is josh malias and i'm a senior
marketing product manager for miltoni
biotek
and thank you for joining this webinar
that focuses on the latest technologies
available to reliably isolate
top quality starting materials for your
drug discovery research
the agenda for today is as follows first
i will briefly provide some background
information about miltoni biotech
next we will discuss the importance of
understanding the various starting
materials used in drug discovery
we will then talk about the various
isolation methods available for the
generation of pbmcs and primary immune
cells
and this will be followed by
highlighting the advantages of automated
cell isolation protocols
finally i will provide the latest
resources available to support your drug
discovery objectives
the words empowering discovery and
advancing therapy
really define our company's mission
which is to improve scientific
understanding
and medical progress by providing
solutions that advance biomedical
research and cellular therapies
as a company we were able to achieve
this mission by our ongoing commitment
bringing newer and smarter technologies
to drug discovery scientists
who are paving the way for longer and
healthier lives
biotech was founded in 1989 by stefan
miltoni
and the basis of the max cell isolation
is the column technology developed as a
part of his diploma thesis
with this technology being patented in
1990
the potential for max technology to
become a revolutionizer in the field of
gene therapy became obvious
and the clinimax cd34 reagent system for
selecting hematopoietic stem cells from
donor apheresis was developed
the clinical evolution of the company
has continued for over 20 years
including setting up a gmp manufacturing
site in federal germany
and in 2014 the fda gave approval for
cd34 isolation using the clinimax
together with the c
the clinimax cd34 reagent
what started out as a diploma thesis has
since grown into a global company of
more than three thousand employees
as well as over twenty thousand
scientific publications citing mex
technology
annually more than twenty five hundred
patients receive cell products
manufactured with multi
military biotech technologies thus
allowing us to recognize our company
mission of advancing biomedical research
and cellular therapies
so what is max technology
max technology is based on three key
components
the max microbeads the reagent max
columns
and the max separator the magnet
together
they enable the magnetic separation of
cell populations based on surface
antigens
this technology is a fast and gentle
method for the isolation of viable and
functional cells by labeling epitopes
with specific antibodies conjugated to
superparamagnetic beads
there are only three easy steps
necessary to generate viable cells
for drug discovery using max technology
first you have the magnetic labeling
where an antibody that's conjugated to a
tiny super paramagnetic microbead that
binds to a surface receptor or protein
on the cell surface
you have the magnetic separation where
the cells are passed through a column
that is positioned within a magnet
the cells labeled with the microbeads
are retained within the column
while everything else is washed through
in a gentle way the flow-through is
called the negative fraction containing
the cells without the ligand for the
antibody or antibodies that were used
in the elusion step step number three
the column is removed from the magnet
enabling the magnetically labeled cells
so the positive fraction
to be washed down this can be done
either manually with a plunger to gently
push the cells out
or it can be automated using a vacuum to
pull the cells out
or increasing the flow speed of the
buffer in the system
all three methods are gentle for the
cells and separate the cells into the
negative and positive fractions with
exceptional purity and high viability
a frequently asked question is why do we
use columns in the first place
the magnetic separators and the column
based and column tree systems have a
comparable magnetic force
but the real differentiator between the
systems is the column
this is filled with small iron spheres
and each ion sphere passes the magnetic
force onto the next one over a very
small distance thus amplifying the
magnetic force by nearly ten thousand
fold
this ensures that the magnetic field is
constant and strong throughout the
column
this system allows for the minimal
labeling of cells with microbeads to
retain the target cells in the column
without relying on
epitope saturation or large beads that
can interfere with downstream
applications such as cell
culture or flow cytometric analysis
the iron spheres have a cell friendly
coating that allows the cells to
run freely through the column and can be
washed thoroughly to remove cell debris
and contaminants
all this contributes to the fact that
the max column allows for highly
effective cell separation
with minimal effects on the cell
originally starting with max technology
30 years ago
miltoni's product portfolio has grown
significantly
and the translational approach from
bench top to bedside is reflective in
all of our products
we provide many of the same products in
both research grade as well as gmp
and clinical quality to ensure smooth
transition into the clinic
we provide a comprehensive offering of
products for drug discovery workflows
this includes tissue dissociation and
homogenization
cell isolation and culture including the
activation and expansion of target
populations
as well as the instrumentation and
reagents for cell analysis and tissue
imaging
now as you might have noticed by now
everything at miltenny biotech
is centered around cells and this brings
me to a critical question
for those attending where do you
normally get primary cells from
and how do you process them for your
downstream assays
to address the first question we will
talk about sourcing blood products as a
starting material
so let's look at the common materials
used for obtaining primary cells and the
steps involved
from your starting materials to sample
preparation
followed by magnetic cell isolation and
downstream applications
every step is critical to ensure
consistent and reproducible downstream
application outcomes
while primary cells can be obtained from
various tissues
most human primary cells come from blood
products such as leukopaks
there can be a fair amount of
flexibility in this area depending on
the number of cells needed in your
downstream applications
whether the starting material is from
whole blood nor bone marrow with limited
cell numbers
to buffy coats or leukopaks which are
larger in size and provide
substantial amounts of quality starting
materials for drug discovery assays
most commonly these are pvmcs and in the
next slides we'll talk about pbmc
isolation
so let's explore the main sources for
pbmcs
whole blood is arguably the most common
starting material used globally
where you can find between one and two
million pbmcs per mill
with the volume being variable depending
on the donor
and frequently provided and different
anticoagulants based on the needs of the
end user
the amount of hematocrit is rather high
typically around 40 to 50 percent
which can have an impact on cell
separation preparation
and downstream assays while the pbmc
concentration in whole blood is rather
low
buffy coats contain on average about 500
million cells in a volume between 30 and
80 mils with
50 mils on average a buffy code is a
waste product generated from
a whole blood donation and the
hematocrit levels vary between four and
ten percent
the same hematocrit levels can be found
in lrscs leukocyte reduction system
chambers or also called buffy cones or
trimacones depending on where you are
these cones contain on average a billion
pbmcs in a rather small volume of only
10 to 15 mils
similar to buffy coats lrscs are a waste
product but
in this case are a waste product of
platelet phoresis
the highest pbmc concentrations can be
found in leukopaks
and they contain up to 10 billion cells
in a full pack
and the volume varies typically between
80 and 200 mils
but sometimes can be up to 300 ml
depending on who your provider is
the hematocrit levels are typically very
low and are less than three percent
so as you can see there are clearly a
lot of differences between these
starting materials
and it's important to know exactly which
material you are working with in order
to use the right cell isolation product
and protocol
the importance of top quality starting
materials cannot be overstated
as experimental success and
reproducibility are contingent on this
aspect of drug discovery whether you're
using
fresh frozen or mobilized leukopaks
whole blood
bone marrow or directly sourced pbmcs
miltennie biotech has become a source
for the most reliable and consistent
blood products on the market
with multiple collection centers
throughout the united states we provide
an extensive donor pool
that allows you to choose from products
based on donor characteristics
and recall ability for more information
about obtaining blood products from
miltoni biotech in the us
and canada please reach out to your
technical sales consultant for ordering
details
once you have obtained the necessary
starting materials that
meet the quality requirements of your
downstream assays
it's necessary to process these cells to
obtain
the cells of interest let's take a look
at the various processes that exist to
do so
typically the sample preparation step
when using blood products such as
whole blood or bone marrow buffy coats
luco packs or lrscs
is traditionally a density gradient
centrifugation step to get pvmcs
now we'll talk about this step in a bit
more detail in just a minute
but first i want to walk you through the
rest of this generic process
now once you've obtained your pbmcs
you would proceed with the steps that we
had previously discussed for magnetic
cell separation
and depending on the project that you
have different options to select from
would you rather go for an easy and fast
positive isolation
or do you need your epitopes free for a
second magnetic isolation so that you
prefer an untouched isolation
or you label everything else except for
the population of interest
do you have multiple samples and would
prefer to separate them and parallel
compared to one after the other
would you rather freeze aliquots of your
pbmcs or isolate the cells directly
all of these factors are important in
deciding which strategy is right for you
at this step
once you have your population of
interest you can then move on to
downstream at applications whether it's
an additional
magnetic cell separation of
subpopulations such as t
regs or the flow cytometric analysis
necessary for immunophenotyping we can
recommend the kits that will make these
steps easier
perhaps you're culturing the cells and
in vitro assays or
are running genomic or proteomic
applications
whether you are interested in maximum
recovery for cell culture assays or
high purity for reliable genomics or
proteomics studies
we can help you with the strategy to get
there
in order to accomplish these objectives
you need top quality starting materials
and for the rest of this webinar we will
be focusing on the latest advancements
in the generation of pbmcs
and primary cells from blood products
now we're going to take a look at a
protocol for isolating pvmcs from
various blood products
so i'm sure i don't have to tell you
what density gradient centrifugation
looks like
without going into too much detail there
are a lot of steps
you have to layer centrifuge count cells
it takes a lot of time and is prone to
human error and user variation
fortunately we have developed new
products that will allow you to bypass
the lengthy density gradient protocol
and get the cells of interest
quickly and reliably
miltoni biotech's density gradient free
solutions
allow you to isolate cells directly from
blood products
without density gradients without cell
counting
and only in a few simple steps you can
completely skip the density gradient
centrifugation
the protocols are very straightforward
and it's easy
and you have the full flexibility in
terms of isolation strategies
at the same time these are the fastest
protocols available for the isolation of
pvmcs and immune cells directly
from the different blood products that
we've discussed earlier
there are very little hands-on steps and
user variation can be reduced
significantly due to the automated
options that you can choose from
when discussing density gradient-free
solutions from miltoni biotech
i'd like to first start out with our
latest offering that allows you to
isolate
truly untouched bbmcs from blood
products
depending on your starting material we
have specific isolation kits available
for the untouched isolation of pvmcs
from peripheral blood
buffy coats lrscs and lego packs
the workflow between these starting
materials is almost identical
so let's just have a look at the
protocol in general
first we sediment the erythrocytes using
a dedicated sedimentation kit
including the pipetting it this only
takes about five minutes
afterwards we take the supernatant and
centrifuge centrifuge for five minutes
after we suspending the cell pellet we
can directly continue with labeling of
the cells with our max microbeads by
adding the reagents
and we incubate for 10 minutes next
the magnetic separation will be done in
our cell separation instruments
which takes between 5 and 20 minutes
depending on your starting materials and
the volumes that you're working with
our protocols ensure that you will only
spend between 25 and 40 minutes to
obtain
untouched pure pdmcs from your blood
sample
when comparing the processes for
generating pbmcs we can
now take this one step further and
compare the total time it takes from
your samples to pbmcs
we've seen how long that density
gradient centrifugation takes
no matter what your starting material is
of course
it also depends on the volumes the
dilution factor you work with
and therefore the number of tubes that
you need to handle
but just to have an example it
definitely takes more than one hour and
possibly more than two hours to process
pbmcs using density gradient
centrifugation
this is what you can see here in purple
now when we compare this to our new pvmc
isolation kit
we immediately see that the protocol is
much faster
independent of the starting material
when working with whole blood
buffy coats buffy cones only 10 minutes
of hands-on time is required for the
preparation and sedimentation step
this means that sedimenting sedimenting
rbc's and taking out the supernatant
spinning for five minutes
is all it takes afterwards
the process including the labeling of
separation is fully automated
for leukopaks the initial sedimentation
of rbcs and the centrifugation of the
supernatant can be skipped
and we can immediately start with the
labeling followed by magnetic cell
separation
without going into the details this
slide is
showing how the composition of pvmcs is
not altered
from the starting material when compared
to traditional density gradient
centrifugation processing
this should give confidence to the end
user that the technology doesn't
selectively deplete any potential
subpopulations of interest
for further downstream assays
now that we have covered our latest
untouched isolation methods for pbmc
generation
we will now turn our attention to our
street firm portfolio that enables the
fast and efficient isolation of multiple
cell types from the same blood sample
similar to our untouched pbmc isolation
products
the protocol for straight from is very
similar independent of the specific
starting materials that you work with
no matter if we're talking about whole
blood
buffy coats lrscs or glucopacks first
you fill the blood sample into a
collection tube
next straight from microbeads are added
and then you incubate for 15 minutes in
the fridge
then the magnetic separation is done on
the multi-max separator or in the case
of whole blood you can also use the auto
max pro separator
in both cases it takes just 30 minutes
from the blood sample to you holding
your target cells in the hand
straights foam is based on a positive
isolation approach from the starting
material and this provides a very
attractive advantage
this advantage would be how positive
selection enables consecutive
separations from the same sample
by using the negative fraction for
another round of separation
here we have an example first you
isolate
cd8 positive t cells and then take the
negative fraction
for isolation of cd4 positive cells
you could take this even another step
further and isolate another round of
subpopulations from that negative
fraction
therefore if you're interested in
several target cell populations from the
same blood sample
this may be the ideal product for your
experiment
a frequent question that we encounter
when discussing our positive selection
reagents has to do with the
performance and downstream functionality
of the cells that are isolated
in this case we've checked for t cell
enrichment
t-cell activation and transduction
efficiency as compared to
density gradient centrifugation and as
expected
we have comparable results but of course
the t cells and the separation were done
much faster using the straight from
approach
this means that our isolation will allow
you to choose the cells of interest
with no negative side effects on your
downstream results
but allowing you to be more efficient at
the same time
in this next section i will talk about
automating your cell isolation
workflow now why do we actually
need automation what is the advantage
as we've already said a little earlier
automation reduces hands-on time and
frees you up to work on other tasks in
the meantime that can't be automated
it minimizes the variation between
different users in the lab or
even a good or bad day from the same
individual
and of course it minimizes costly human
errors
with standard protocols and minimum user
variation
you can be sure that the effects that
you're seeing are due to your assay
rather than artifacts
in short automation reduces redundant
experiments and allows you to focus your
time where it matters
when introducing our family of automated
cell separators we'll start with the
auto max pro
the easy to use bench top instrument for
every laboratory
with fully automated sequential
separation of one to six samples
the auto max provides easy access to the
automation without
high investment costs or lots of
training you can mix
many different starting materials and
samples within one run
and just hit the button and the
instrument will label and separate the
cells for you
the columns are reusable so maintenance
is easy
and column cost can be reduced the
instrument is the perfect match for the
isolation of pbmcs from peripheral blood
and buffy coats
but of course also target cells that can
be isolated from pvmcs within the auto
max pro
if you are interested in isolating
multiple samples in parallel
the multi-max family is a perfect fit
for this
24 magnets allow you to process between
1 and 24 samples in a single run
or split or split your large samples
between multiple columns
this is achieved by using the ls ld or
whole blood columns
or the multi 24 column block for easy
easy handling of 24 samples or perhaps a
very large sample
like an entire leukopak the multi-max
cell 24 is a
semi-automated instrument that is a good
fit for many labs that
value easy handling but don't mind the
manual pipetting
however if you want full automation and
maximum throughput
you will love the multi-max x which
integrates the multi-max into a liquid
handler
the multi-max x is the instrument for
the high demanding
high-throughput cell processing lab
samples are labeled and isolated
automatically
both for pbmc generation or
subpopulations from all blood products
all programs are tailored to match your
needs so you can be confident
that you will be satisfied with the
protocol and the results delivered from
this instrument
so we're coming to the end of the
presentation and there are a few things
that i want you to keep in mind when
thinking about
density gradient free solutions for cell
isolation with max technology
it should be no secret that the success
of any experiment depends on the quality
of the starting material
so remember that the right cell
preparation and isolation steps are
crucial
in the beginning of any workflow to
ensure reliable assay results
automating these processes with the help
of our cell separation instruments
combined with our density gradient free
protocols
allow you to be more efficient while
ensuring high reproducibility and
standardization
our new methods enable you to isolate
target cells or pbmcs directly from
blood products with high speed
great performance and easy protocols
i'd like to thank everyone for attending
this webinar
and for the latest updates and resources
available for drug discovery workflows
please come by the booth or stop by our
website
thank you and take care